callen hooper sénateurs les républicains
de la côte d'or alain houpert bonjour
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors calendrier des écoles
maintenu masques pour les collégiens
aide financière aux étudiants les plus
précaires ou encore aides aux
entreprises beaucoup souhaitaient de la
précision est ce que vous y voyez plus
clair aujourd'hui
non j'ai eu un premier ministre fatigué
toujours dans la dramatisation et la
rigidité alors que les français aspirent
de la confiance et de la responsabilité
responsabilisation et on peut concéder
qu en europe
l'europe est une modèle qui est à cet
égard angela merkel qui elle est une
professionnelle me souvenais de données
du maquereau qui disait que kiel ou est
ce une députée d'être des amateurs et
dans les pierres anglais la marque elle
semble avoir mieux géré la crise
alors alain houpert votre groupe
sénatorial pense que la stratégie de
déconfinement du gouvernement expose
pénalement les élus locaux edouard
philippe a répondu je le cite a précisé
la loi c'est oui mais atténuer la
responsabilité c'est non comment est-ce
que vous recevez cette réponse du
premier ministre ce d'état qui l'éthique
de déconfinement les écoles primaires
seront sous la responsabilité de
l'éducation nationale et l'accueil sous
la responsabilité des élus locaux en
particulier lui maire et le maire a des
responsabilités énormes mais je
comprends que certains légumes
s'inquiètent et la majorité sénatoriale
justement a justement peut parler
d'amendements et par position mais pour
qu'on relativise cette responsabilité
est qu'on va tout face aux vrais
responsables les vrais responsables ce
sont ceux qui décident et qui décide
c'est l'exécutif et d'exécutif ici c'est
le président nous souhaitons qu'ils
aient plus de le contrôle du parlement
c'est pour ça que nous souhaitons être
active dans la prolongation de cet état
d'urgence parce que cette opération
petit état durant ce qui ralentit tout
qui ralentit tout économiquement
puisqu'il va être de deux mois mais deux
2 mois et en anglais les procédures des
procédures administratives vont pouvoir
perdurer deux mois après la fin de
l'état d'urgence
donc imaginez en france les délais sur
les permis de construire les délais
administratifs la france économique est
en état de coma il faut la sortir de ce
coma et doit être fait dans la rapidité
alors autre sujet qui suscite la
polémique est à aborder également par le
premier ministre on l'a entendu certains
pensent qu'il ya eu un stock caché de
masques dans la grande distribution ce
qui a été démenti par le premier
ministre est-ce que selon vous il faut
éclaircir cette question à rugles a élu
là il ya un problème de responsabilité
est levée chrome os est ce qu'on appelle
la réquisition 1 qui date plutôt de
l'ancien monde de la guerre de 14 ou de
la guerre de 1940
l'acquis la récession a cassé la chaîne
logistique
elle a empêché ses plateformes d'achat
et l'importation quand vous importez
vous payez cash sur le tarmac est allé
les chinois qui nous vendent
actuellement et c'est dommage parce que
toute la production maintenant puisqu'on
a déjà souscrit à l'idée se fait en asie
et en chine
église d'être payés rapidement ils
savent très bien que l'état paye à 68 90
jours ou quand ils payent donc la
réquisition à la casse est complètement
c'est pour ça que la france est en
criant que deux ans que de wagons de la
production de match et là il ya une
forte responsabilité de l'état une forte
responsabilité du ministre qui a admis
réquisitions alors pour conclure en
quelques mots le président emmanuel
macron assez justement lui aussi exprimé
cet après midi et il appelle à aborder
le déconfinement avec je cite calme
pragmatisme et bonne volonté les
français vont l'entendre
oui des français vont les français le
veulent les français les français
souffrent de solitude
et puis le le confinement il se fait de
manière vraiment très inégale regardez
les mesures de police générale qui sont
disproportionnées à l'échelle nationale
et elle dépend de la configuration des
lieux discipline collective
il faut laisser les maires jugés au plus
près du terrain pour ça que le sénat
demande une réduction de la durée de
l'état d'urgence et on en discutera avec
le gouvernement
cet après midi parce que il faut
absolument que le parlement fonctionne à
nouveau normalement
merci beaucoup alain houpert d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes sénateur les républicains de
la côte d'or